this video is made possible by Vince
arrow watch's luxury handcrafted watches
at fair prices you can check him out at
vince arrow watches dot-com /pi graphics
link in the description below is the sad
fact that evil men are often as well
remembered as history's good guys for
every Abraham Lincoln or Gandhi there
are a dozen hitless or starlings or
Dharma's or Bundy's well you get the
idea we've covered them a lot here abaya
graphics tragic as it is to admit one of
the most surefire ways of being
remembered
is to make life a misery for millions of
people but what if we told you there was
a man responsible for the deaths of tens
or hundreds of thousands of people who
you've never heard of a serial killer
who committed massacres raped with
impunity and helped one of the worst
dictators in history carry out his
heinous crimes while not only did this
man unfortunately exist he only died in
1953 his name was Lavrentiy Beria
Stalin's architect of terror the feared
head of Stalin's NKVD Baria was directly
responsible for some of the USSR's worst
crimes he took charge of an ethnic
cleansing in the Soviet Union after
World War two he raped dozens of women
murdered with his own bare hands and
once sent over 22,000 people to their
deaths with a single swipe of his pen in
the video today we're looking at the
gruesome story of the man whose name
once made half of Europe tremble in fear
and how he came to vanish from the
history books
[Music]
they say that monsters are not born but
that they're made it's a comforting
thought but it's difficult to square
with what we know of this man when he
was born in Georgia in 1899 it wasn't
exactly into circumstances that scream
this kid's gonna be a mass murderer
young levanti's life was boring ly
normal as far though as a poor farmer
and his mother was a faded noble stock
while his father would disappear from
his life when a frenzy was young runaway
fathers don't normally create killers if
they did Charlie Chaplin would be famous
today not for slaying them with laughter
but for literally slaying them however
there was one other fatherless Georgian
who grew up to be a mass killer like
Lavrentiy he was born into rural Georgia
to a poor family in the late 19th
century like lorenzi his father dropped
out of his life at a tender age his name
was Joseph Stalin not that the two men
knew each other in Georgia anything is
narrative ly pleasing as that Stalin was
over 20 when Lavrentiy was born in 1916
as the Communists prepared to detonate a
revolutionary bomb that would shake the
world
Lavrentiy was a simple nobody studying
engineering in Baku which is modern-day
Azerbaijan it wasn't until the upheaval
of 1917 s February revolution that
barrier even joins the Communist Party
but that joining of the Communist Party
well it would turn out to be a heck of a
career move barely was the ink dry on
barriers membership card than the
tsunami of the October Revolution came
crashing over Europe one of the single
most significant events of the 20th
century the October Revolution saw the
Bolsheviks seize control of Russia bring
Lenin back from exile and begin the
entire process that would soon lead to
the Soviet Union Ferreria
this was a right place at the right time
sort of deal the new communists recruit
got enthusiastically involved in
counterintelligence in baku quickly
becoming a useful agent he was there
when the russian civil war that exploded
after the Bolshevik coup swept into
Azerbaijan in 1920 and in the chaos he
was accidentally arrested as a counter
revolutionary by the Red Army
he was almost executed only a timely
intervention by the Azzurri communist
leaders saved him
wanting to make sure he never wounds up
in such a precarious position again
Barry a quickly moved to formalize his
position as a Bolshevik
counterintelligence agents so he joined
the checker at the time the checker was
in the midst of the Red Terror a series
of massacres aimed at anyone who didn't
support Lenin's dictatorship somewhere
between 28 and 200 thousand died a
number compounded by the simultaneous
white terror which targeted those who
did support Lenin and killed up to
another 100,000 for agent barrier now
back in his native Georgia this was a
fight to the death not that white army
had much of a presence in Georgia the
real problem there was Georgian
nationalists in the chaotic aftermath of
the revolution Georgia had declared
independence from Moscow briefly in 1921
the Soviets sent the tanks in and well
that was the end of that at least it was
for the army for men like barrier this
was the exact time they were needed the
most in the first few years of Soviet
rule barrier helped set up a spy network
that infiltrated and smashed gangs of
nationalists dragging their members off
the execution or a long ride to side
areas distant gulags promoted to deputy
chairman of the Georgian checker barrier
was key to crushing the failed
nationalist Revolution of 1924 a small
number of historians even think barrier
orchestrated the uprising himself to
justify a violent crackdown whatever the
truth here the checkered revolution it
was brutal area cut a deal with captured
revolt leaders to make supporters lay
down their arms then proceeded to
Massacre everyone who had surrendered
estimates are sketchy but as many as
10,000 Georgians may have been executed
on the orders of barrier whole villages
were wiped out in one gruesome episode
checker operatives went into a town
rounded up anyone with a certain surname
and guns them all down including women
children and even babies not long after
barrier was at a Communist Party
conference flush with his recent bloody
success he was introduced to a fellow
Georgian Joseph Stalin then still three
years away from becoming undisputed
leader of the USSR was apparently
impressed with what he saw because he
and barrier they hit it off big time
it would be the start of one of the
bloodiest partnerships in modern history
the next few years of their years life
can be divided into two distinct
categories consolidating his power base
in Georgia and furiously brown-nosing
Stalin like a sentient suppository the
butcher of Georgia slowly slithered his
way up the greasy pole of power
dispatching enemies here sending
innocents off to the gulag there and
other such things as his brutality grew
so did his stature barrier rose to party
chairman of Georgia where he instituted
a personality cult around himself that
was based on Stalin's this was a
remarkably difficult act to pull off
while imitation might be the sincerest
form of flattery anyone in the Soviet
system who built a power base to rival
Stalin tended to wind up with a terminal
case of death it might have helped here
that barrier was a magnificent suck-up
every time he saw Stalin he showered him
with praise he took over the dictators
of vacation security detail even built a
holiday home next to Stalin's villa in a
near identical style but of course
smaller if there was one thing barrier
knew well it was how to appeal to
Stalin's vanity by 1934 barrier was one
of Stalin's cheerleaders on the party's
all-important Central Committee and one
of the walrus mustache leaders
confidants he had been promoted to
chairman of the entire Transcaucasian
region which is modern-day Georgia
Azerbaijan and Armenia for an average
kid from Nowheresville this was probably
higher than it ever expected to rise in
his wildest dreams but barrier was
nothing if not ambitious in 1935 he
finally made his move the move that
would take him out of the sticks and
into Moscow's corridors of power he
wrote a book yep a book various ghosts
written on the history of the Bolshevik
organizations in Transcaucasia was
spectacularly dull unless you happen to
be at one of the major stars of its
historical narrative get to guess who
might all fill those boots that was
absolutely right of course it was Stalin
the area's book was essentially a puff
it's kind of like reading a fawning
article in Vanity Fair but with much
more bloodshed unsurprisingly Stalin
loved it
the books publications cemented barrier
in his list of personal favorites in a
few short years it would be the catalyst
for barriers next big promotion but
first we have to deal with the great
terror if the Red Terror was the warm-up
act the great terror also known as the
Great Purge was the headliners taking to
the main stage while fireworks exploded
in the crowd screams with paralyzing
fear in this case launched in 1934
following the assassination of Sergei
Kirov it began as a clearing of the
Communist Party's ranks before
ballooning into a general cleansing of
the entire USSR random quotas were
distributed in republics like
Transcaucasia insuring anyone could be
snatched off the streets and executed at
any time scientists artists soldiers
peasants foreigners ethnic minorities
and more war wiped out children of
dissidents were shot for the crimes of
their parents today it's thought that a
bare minimum of 750,000 people died with
some estimating the figure is twice as
high as that the architect of all this
terror was a man known as Nikolai Jakov
the head of the NKVD which had
eventually succeed at the checkered but
yeah job he didn't work in a vacuum in
the local republics of the USSR then
like Berrier enthusiastically followed
his lead and barriers watch
Transcaucasia became a sea of blood he
used the purge to have old political
opponents murdered tried to wipe out
minorities and settled petty scores with
bullets it was a crazy
horrifying time and anyone could have
been next and barrier he very nearly was
by 1938 years of was in a killing frenzy
a friend of barriers in Moscow sent him
an urgent message saying the NKVD had
added him to their list of targets
terrified barrier did the only thing he
could he caught a plane to Moscow and
begged Stalin for his life various
survival was not a foregone conclusion
though for a couple of years Stalin had
been hinting that he was getting ball
with fellow Georgian he no longer
vacationed near Barry Aaron's while he'd
loved barriers Burke had also nodded
through the dissolution of Transcaucasia
taking barrier from head honcho of three
nations to just Georgia realistically
barrier probably had a 50/50 chance of
stepping off the plane and simply
getting shot
luckily Marion landed in Moscow just as
Stalin completely fell out with years
off after indulging barriers went that
please for a while Stalin essentially
said to barrier you know what how about
you take over as deputy head of the NKVD
you'll answer only two yes off and me
and frankly only one of those guys
counts because in a couple of months
you're going to have the other one
execute it got it and this is how
barrier went in a handful of weeks from
marked for death to head of the NKVD
yessuf was purged and barrier was placed
in charge of ending the great terror yep
ending it barrier may have been
bloodthirsty but he was not stupid
Stalin wanted the terror to wind down so
wine down it did barrier officially
ended the purges the executions the
exiles all of that stuff
he released some prisoners and
eliminated the use of purely sadistic
torture in the gulags if that seems a
little off-key think of barrier kind of
like Adolf Eichmann he had absolutely no
problem with unimaginable cruelty but
what he hated more was inefficiency and
if you want to learn more about the
monster that was Eichmann please do
check out our biographic Svidler on that
whole link to it in the description of
the lobe and when it comes to a god
torturing a random prisoner just to get
his kicks well that was a guard who
could have been torturing a known
dissident to extract information
it was simply wasted calories Marija
ended 1938 in a good place had survived
a purge that had wiped out 1/3 of the
entire Communist Party had been elevated
to head of the NKVD the most feared
organization in the whole of the USSR
and had done all of this while retaining
his weird personality cult in Georgia he
also had Stalin's favor something that
was no small deal when falling-out with
Stalin meant being drags like yes off
into a freezing Moscow courtyard and
shot so what does a man like Baria do
when handed the power of light
and death over the whole of the USSR
plus say get-out-of-jail-free card
signed by Stalin by the way well
unfortunately for the rest of his
countrymen we're about to find out
[Music]
Kattan is a tiny community in the Far
West of Russia near the ballot Russian
border in May 1940 the Red Army
slaughtered 22,000 polish POWs there and
dumped them in a mass grave known today
as the cation massacre it was one of
barriers most infamous actions as the
head of the NKVD
oh and believe me the were other
contenders barrier helped to organize
and carry out the assassination of Leon
Trotsky in Mexico City in 1940 he purged
the Red Army in the middle of World War
two sending high-ranking generals off to
the gulag in the dying days of the war
he even oversaw a mass scale ethnic
cleansing program against minorities in
the USSR the most infamous of these was
the deportation of the Crimean Tatars
which killed up to 8,000 people that it
happens and another twenty to thirty
thousand when they arrived at the
destination all this carnage
and barrier the nickname the Soviet
hemlock
but it's barriers unofficial actions
that sit uneasily today in his spare
hours away from the NKVD and supervising
the Soviet atomic bomb project Berea had
a gruesome hobby that he pursued with a
psychopathic diligence this hobby was
being Moscow's rapist in chief after
dark barrier would be driven around
Moscow until he saw a pretty girl his
goons would then kidnap Arryn's bring
her to barriers mansion in the suburbs
their area would Wine and Dine the
unfortunate wench take her to a spare
bedroom and rape her
girls who suffered at his hand would be
handed a bouquet of flowers the next
morning as they left the house taking
heads would mean the sex had been
consensual refusing it well there are
conflicting stories most accounts
suggest a girl who refused barriers gift
could see her family sent to the gulag
but there are other even darker
possibilities in the 1990s the Tunisian
Embassy moved into barriers old mansion
while doing work they found the bones of
dozens of teenage girls buried in a
garden
it seems barriers deviant appetites they
did not stop with rape various
predilections were an open secret
amongst the USSR's higher-ups Stalin
himself once told his own daughter to
never accept a ride from barrier Nikita
Khrushchev himself no stranger to murder
openly both feared
and loathed the head of the NKVD yes
Barry a star kept rising and rising some
of even suggested Berio was the clear
choice for the next head of the Soviet
Union in the event of Stalin's death so
now you might be wondering well why
didn't that happen well in order to
answer that question we need to skip
ahead to 1953 to the death of Joseph
Stalin on the 1st of March 1953 Stalin
was discovered on the floor of his dacha
barely conscious and on the brink of
death
happily for all those who believed in
karma he spent the next five days in
miserable agony before finally passing
away in his memoirs Nikita Khrushchev
wrote that Barry has spent those five
days weeping and kissing Stalin's hands
when it looked like The Dictator would
recover and grinning like a schoolboy
and it looked like he was going to die
wacht reshef isn't the most reliable
witness to anything to do with his old
enemy barrier he may be right on the
money here there's a rumor the barrier
was falling out of Stalin's favour in
1953 barrier has long been suspected of
secretly poisoning the dictator to save
his own skin although no firm evidence
has ever emerged weather barrier did the
deed or merely benefited from it there's
no doubting that Stalin's death fired
something in his withered old heart as
an epic power struggle erupted between
Khrushchev and malankov for the now
vacated throne barrier got the drop on
them by doing something unexpected he
transformed into a statesman in anyways
the last hundred days of barriers life
are the most fascinating history today
remembers Khrushchev's secret speech
denouncing Stalin in 1956 three years
after the monster died barrier was
denouncing Stalin within three weeks one
of his first acts was to play the
party's Central Committee secret tapes
that had recorded of his conversations
with Stalin to convince them his former
mentor had been wacko by the end before
March 1953 was out barrier had
unilaterally released over a million
prisoners from the gulags by April it
bans the use of torture across the USSR
shortly after that he returned as the
passports of over 4 million dissidents
had been sent into internal exile it was
a speed and scale
of reform that left the Soviet world
dizzy these were just the reforms that
barrier actually got around to
implementing under his grand vision
barrier wanted to reunite East and West
Germany and then let them vote on
whether to remain socialist he plans to
tone down censorship and allow the
various Soviet republics to forge their
own national identities something that
could easily have led to independence
it's hard to believe but barriers plans
for the USSR
were nothing short of an enlightened
revolution so all of this now raises an
interesting question how sincere was he
clearly barrier was an ambitious man
clearly he was also not that thrilled
with the direction of Stalin's reign in
its last few years but as we've already
seen he was also a murderer a sexual
predator and a semi genocide or monster
it seems hard to believe that the man
who had sent millions to the gulags
could have secretly wanted to release
them all along maybe he was a real
reformer maybe it was all a cynical
power play to get the public on his side
until he could snatch the crown from
Khrushchev and Malikov in a great
historical irony the only other reformer
in stalin's in a circle began to move
against barrier almost as quickly as
barrier moved against him Nikita
Khrushchev would go down in history as
the Soviet premier who instituted
de-stalinization yet in 1953 his only
concern was removing the one guy as
enthusiastic about reform as he was for
100 days after Stalin's death barrier
Khrushchev and Malikov jostled for power
finally something happened that flipped
the cards in Khrushchev favor
East Germany exploded in revolt on June
the 16th a factory worker protest in
socialist East Germany transformed into
a widespread uprising against local
communist authorities hundreds of
thousands rioted across the nation many
more fled to West Berlin in the
confusion of Stalin's death and barriers
reforms the socialist authorities in
East Germany had eased up on their
hardline implementation of socialism and
now the people were an open revolt it
was all the excuse that barriers enemies
needed back in Moscow Khrushchev
successfully blamed the revolt on
barriers regime of liberalisation
forcing an alliance with malankov
Molotov to vent
Minister Nikolai Bulganin and marshal
Zhukov he arranged for barrier to be
called in for a closed meeting at the
end of June what happened next is
shrouded in mystery
Khrushchev apparently read a speech
furiously denouncing barriers crimes and
branding him a traitor the climax was
meant to be a signal for Malin cough to
push a hidden button summoning zhukov's
men but in the heat of the moment he
forgot and barrier was able to beg his
friends for his life before the officers
finally rushed in after that
everything's just speculation one
version of the tale has it the barrier
was dragged out to an anteroom and shot
in the head before you could even figure
out what was going on another hazard
that he was smuggled out past his own
guards and brought to a grotty basement
where men versed in NKVD interrogation
techniques turned barriers own methods
upon him some say he was tortured others
say he was simply imprisoned before
being pulled before a kangaroo court
tried and executed by firing squad the
only thing we know for certain is that
at some points between June the 26th and
his official trial on December the 23rd
he was killed many sources contends that
Berio was dead long before his case went
to court and his trial was just a
rubber-stamp her actions already taken
it said that his body was incinerated
and his ashes scattered with a giant fan
perhaps unsurprisingly any of his NKVD
associates were also rounded up and
executed
Berrien had been stuffing the agency
with loyalists from Georgia for years
and a bloody purge of the whole outfit
was inevitable with his death barrier
disappeared from history his name was
scrubbed from Soviet records the mere
mention of him was frowned upon his
reforms they were reversed only to be
partially implemented again by his old
enemy Khrushchev just a few years later
today those living in the West have
barely heard of him
the barrier left a peculiar mark on
history or maybe perhaps a stain on the
one hand he was personally responsible
for hundreds of thousands of deaths he
also raped countless women and was
probably a serial killer and left
millions of lives shattered in his wake
but he was also the first reformer to
briefly lead the USSR and the first to
dare to talk about de-stalinization with
his reforms he could have ushered in a
Thor in the Cold War
or he could have simply stepped the
repression right back up again after his
enemies were liquidated was he simply a
monster or was he maybe something more
as is so often the case with history the
answer can sadly only be we'll never
know now just before we end today's
video I do want to take a moment to tell
you about Vince aro watches I'm wearing
one of these right now this is a Vince
Eric chronograph as well as keeping
perfect time it's got a time of the
three dials in the back there they look
great but they also serve the function
of a timer I picked out a watch with a
blue and silver combination but there
are loads of options on the website
you'll be sure to find something that
suits your style and your wrist size by
the way I have tiny little wrists so
they sent me a smaller version of the
watch so that was that's that's really
great fits perfectly now I've been
putting this watch through its paces
over the last few weeks and it's still
looking as good as the day I took it out
of the box great durable leather no
scratches on the face anything like that
it's really looking grand Vince Aero
believes that luxury isn't about price
or specification it's about detail it's
about craftsmanship and Vince Aero
watches they have a lot of that unlike
many other watches on the market Vince
era isn't about minimalist style it's
more about that classic great look of a
watch which is something I personally
love I think this really sets itself
apart from other watches on the market
it's really a good looking thing further
by selling direct to the customer Vince
era can deliver a great watch at about a
tenth of the price that you might expect
so go check out the full range of
watches at Vince era watches com forward
slash buyer graphics link in the
description below also use the code bio
graphics on checkout for a special
discount
thanks to Vince era watches for
sponsoring this video thank you for
watching don't forget to subscribe like
all of that good stuff and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]